c'est un être humain conçu
plus fort plus vite plus intelligent que les gens normaux
il s'appelle 47 ans il est là pour te tuer
trouve la fille tout ce qu'il faut
aujourd'hui est la clé de tout tu sais
pourquoi tu es toujours en vie
parce que j'ai choisi de ne pas te tuer mais ils
pourquoi veulent-ils me tuer nous faisions
partie du même programme ils veulent
ce qu'il y a dans notre ADN d'accord tu es
pareil que moi alors détache toi
dis moi comment faire un agent tu ne veux pas
les Natchez
tu veux une armée  verset 7 vous êtes une
légende et mieux
assez fou hein soyez une armure corporelle en titane sous-cutanée
et l'avantage des agents n'est pas son
copain c'est mauvais
qu'allez-vous faire
je vais brûler ce frère dans le sol
et vous pouvez m'aider
mr.  Chanin tu saurais qui je suis
toi